you mentioned earlier uh feminism and I
think it's really important to talk
about this because whether it be first
second or third wave feminism and those
were very different obviously uh you
know tell talk to us a little bit about
the impact and you know has that helped
women or hurt women of course I have my
own thoughts on that but
well I mean you're going to get a
different answer depending on who you
ask but my opinion is I don't think it's
helped women I think it's hurt Society
um I think it's it's now convinced like
it's at the stage where it's not really
for equality I don't think you'd find
anybody out there that would argue that
women can't do or have anything that men
have today as far as job opportunity I
mean there's a big push to get you know
women into boardrooms as CEOs and
members you know of these types of
levels but there's no push to get women
onto oil rigs coal mines and on garbage
trucks so it's kind of selective it's
kind of like an A La Carte menu
um which sort of turns it into a
Supremacy movement at this point is the
way that it's going where it actually
kind of aims to have women dislike men
not see them as peers not want to be
their equals but actually want to push
them down and you've got a legal system
that sort of complies with that with
family law you have a legal system that
complies with that with you know the
whole hashtag metoo era so there's a lot
of things there's a lot of moving Parts
with these mechanisms so I mean we can
go down that rabbit hole depends on how
far you want to take your audience in
that one my friend yeah yeah no exactly
but it um in interestingly it seems like
it has created a lot of lonely people
and uh a culture that is just more and
more detached you know you talk about
the government's role and uh some people
say the government is the new husband
and uh the government is the head of the
household now yeah you know there used
to be a time where the man was ahead of
the household and he had responsibility
of his family along with authority uh
today if you're a married man you you
still have responsibility to the family
financially obviously but you don't have
any Authority anymore uh the government
and the woman is now the head of the
household so that's just the way that
things are today and that's just the
direction that we've pushed in based on
the you know all the decisions that we
made and where we've gone with it all
so if we layer into that the impact of
social media uh Instagram is the new
boyfriend uh but not really it's sort of
this attention
um reward dopamine reward system and
this is much different for women than it
is for men because uh you know if men
post a picture on Instagram they're not
going to get 5 000 comments so you're
beautiful you're handsome whatever right
you know it just doesn't work the same
way uh between the genders does it it
doesn't and it's actually interesting
because I noticed this a while ago so
I'm going to pick up my phone here and
the way that men use social media and
Instagram is they'll take their phone
and be like oh there's there's a nice
car let me take a picture of that or
there's a nice Canyon over there let me
take a picture of that but women on the
other hand they take the phone and they
do it and they use it like this right
because they're pointing the camera that
way so you know women use it for
validation and to get attention
um
it's an addiction for a lot of women for
guys I think they're more addicted to
competitive areas like on video games
um they're not so concerned with getting
likes based on their latest selfie
picture whereas that seems to be the
case for women so it's used very very
differently you know between the
different sexes
you know I remember uh being at a
conference about 20 years ago when
um
the job boards were gaining popularity
and you know monster.com was the big job
board back then right and uh the the
talk was about how every employee now on
LinkedIn of course basically is always
up for grabs their resume is always
online they're always available for hire
and now that's become that way where
particularly women because the genders
act very differently in the way they
engage with social media are always
available and um you know in in the
entrepreneurship world you and I I'm
sure both uh you know I'm sure you know
about the the software called click
funnels right it's a funnel building
software and that's how you do sales
through a sales funnel and Instagram is
essentially a sales funnel and uh
it it's like can anyone even be in a
relationship anymore because if they
have a social profile
and they're on Instagram and they
exhibit this massive amount of
narcissism where it's just all these
like selfie pictures it's just frankly
weird I mean if someone looked at this
you know someone time traveled from a
couple decades ago and saw this they
would think have people gone nuts I mean
this is just like take it out of context
and look at how weird this is the
culture we live in yeah it is weird I'm
glad that you mentioned that because one
of the things that I talked to a lot of
guys about especially when they're
contemplating a relationship or if
they're contemplating inviting a woman
into their life as a mother and you know
forming a family is one of the
conversations you have to have when when
when she comes at you and says uh hey
Jason you know where do we uh stand you
know I want to be exclusive with you I
don't want to share your blah blah sort
of thing that's that's the point where
you need to take a look at her social
presence and if she's the kind of gal
that has a Instagram and she posts uh
selfies provocative selfies
um you know herself on a very regular
basis on a public social media site you
have to have that conversation say look
you know I dig your Vibe too but I don't
get into relationships with women that
behave this way so if you want to be
with me this is something that you're
going to have to give up
um and that's the choice that that
she'll have to make if she sees him as
her hypergamous best option if she sees
him as the guy that she wants to be with
then she'll abandon that if she doesn't
then she'll probably push back and say
something like oh you're controlling why
are you jealous that's whatever right so
um yeah it's an interesting time and
it's a conversation our parents
certainly didn't have to have with our
mothers yeah no question about it
explain the hypergamy if you would
yeah it's it's just a it's a feature of
women's dating strategy uh it's not a
bug it's something that evolutionary
psychology has uh discussed for decades
now and all that it really means is that
women prefer to settle uh for men of
greater value than themselves so women
date across and up on the socio-economic
hierarchy which is why you'll see a you
know Kevin who's a VP of the accounting
department at a large company uh Mary a
woman that might be a forty five
thousand dollar a year hairdresser it's
pretty common it's actually one of the
things that my divorce lawyer brought to
my attention well over a decade ago when
we were having our conversations and you
know he did mention that he's it's very
very very rare that he sees divorce
cases where Mister makes less money than
misses right Mr as always
um you know the guy that's usually got a
higher ranking job
um and she's making a lot less money
doesn't have the same skill set but
that's because women marry a cross
enough then I said that's a feature not
a bug because women have always been
that way because if they weren't that
way then their offspring wouldn't have a
very good chance to survive you go back
a thousand years if she made a mate
choice and got pregnant by the loser of
the tribe who didn't have any resources
who couldn't hunt who couldn't provide
who couldn't protect the family it would
spell certain death so that still
happens today but it looks it looks a
little bit different in the sexual
Marketplace because women don't really
need protection there's the police force
there's the military women don't really
need a man for money because they can go
to work but they still prefer to date
across and up which is why one of the
complaints a lot of the gals have today
a lot of these professional women that
have you know gone and chased Excellence
they've got their degrees and uh you
know they're 35 years old is they're
they're making good money they're making
great money they're making 100 200 000 a
year and they're having a very very hard
time finding a guy that is willing to
um you know marry them and sort of
family with them but what they fail to
realize is the guys that they're looking
at the 35 40 45 year old guys are
looking at women as Beauty objects
because that's the difference between
men and women men see women as Beauty
objects and women see men as success
objects so again you know women are
hypergamous they look up that guys
whereas men look at Beauty because
they're looking at women for fertility
reasons so these guys around their age
are a little bit older are generally
dating younger women especially if
they're successful and they got their
head screwed on right yeah it's it's
interesting how uh
sort of incongruous the the genders are
in terms of what they're looking for
right you know that yeah that that is
complementary and they've always been
complimentary it's just that the way
Society is sort of moving today it's
it's it's masculinizing more women and
it's feminizing more uh guys so like
there's a there's a pretty big divide so
what you were talking about earlier at
the start of the show is yeah there's
going to be more households with two
toasters and two couches and probably
kids moving back and forth or in some
cases you know scenarios where it's just
a single parent household and one parent
is just moving their resources to the
other parents so yeah that's that's
where we are today but I don't know
where they're gonna go with that like
how are they going to double down and
and and split that scenario so that they
can double up on you know tax revenue
and you know job creation all that stuff
you really can't go very much farther
after you split up a family yeah they've
already they've already sort of
maximized that unfortunately it's child
labor maybe I don't know yeah yeah we're
gonna have nine-year-olds with their own
houses and couches and toasters who
knows what they're going to try next
maybe those kids have rights you know
like
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out